morty préparez-vous pour des feux d'artifice
[Musique]
un peu hors de caractère pour dire
cela maintenant mais vous avez l'air vraiment cool
alors faisons-le
la porte ouvre la porte rick est-ce le
matin
tout le monde attaque un à la fois est que
la meilleure façon de  voir quelque chose de génial
oui
dieu pourquoi tout le monde va cyberpunk oiseaux
c'est pourquoi tu voulais sortir de la ville
tu penses que je te mentirais sur pourquoi nous sommes
en vacances morty
je ne te mentirais pas bien c'est un mensonge
hein
quoi  sommes-nous devenus pourquoi faisons-nous
ça parce que c'est amusant toi petit
rat
morty ça va sonner mal mais me ferais-
tu confiance pour ne pas te tuer
ah eh bien je n'ai pas vraiment le temps de
déballer cette
[Musique]
oh mon dieu viens  sur allons-y